i was in the car with some friends and
and she like mentioned something and i
go wait you shave and she's like you
don't
and like looked at me like i was a
monster and i was like i can't let
anybody near my [ __ ] until i figure out
what's going on here
hello and welcome to the roast of your
teenage self podcast
i am your host your roast coming queen a
girl who once cried while reading a fan
fiction about green day elise morales
and with us today we have the beauty
talk shock jock the queen of creams the
host with the most serums the freshest
fringe on the west coast the pop
punk princess your kooky southern jewish
aunt and the host of the natch puke
podcast but before all of that
she was a graduate of south garland high
school it's jackie johnson
that was the best intro thank you so
much for having me elise
i really wanted to make sure i got i
know that there was a low-rise
jeans there's a low-rise jeans queen
that was in there at one point
at one point and i couldn't remember if
there was uh if
there was a date attached to it oh maybe
maybe of the mid-2000s
that might have been it the the low-rise
jean queen of the
might which is mid-2000s a really
important thing for us to address
it is and and honestly i want that on my
tombstone
[Laughter]
with like some filigree around it you
know
it'll look really lovely our producer
and i were just talking about i feel
like there's
always every like couple of months
i'll see something that's like low-rise
jeans are back and it's like meant to
scare us all
yeah i mean you would probably know
better than me being a younger person
but remember the whole tick tock
you can't wear skinny jeans thing that
really that
triggered stress in my body i was like i
can't deal with this right now what what
are we supposed to be wearing
i'm not going back to the jinko look
that did not serve my body type
but here so here's how i've like
contextualized this with the
with the teens on tick-tock yeah that
like i'm 30.
if it's if you look so young i thought
you were like going to be like i'm 22
and a half
thank you so much it's the zoom filter
honey
well i listened to you oh yes
we love so um i
the the thing that helped me to get over
my
what the jen's ears were saying about
the millennials is basically being like
okay if a
30 year old in 2005 had worn the same
clothes that i was wearing
they would have looked clinically insane
so yeah like we don't need we don't need
to be wearing the same like a 30 year
old in 2005 dressed in like hot topic
pants
and like like manic panic hair
just a lot of bad plaid yeah like
like a really big pocket with chains on
it like that's not
got to chain the wallet you never know
that's not what an
adult woman needs to be wearing so
that's how i'm
i'm just like you know what i don't need
to be wearing the same thing as them
yeah that's actually a really beautiful
empowering point
and i will take that today because i was
stressed about this i mean look at my
side part you know i can't keep
up with the kids and that's something
that you just have to kind of realize
and as you come into your 30s you sort
of realize oh wait it's okay
that i don't keep up with the kids yeah
i don't have to
that's the beauty of getting older
exactly i don't need to be
at the you know the cutting edge
yes i don't need to always know what's
going on i don't need to know who lil
yachty is you know these are things i
can just release
abs you can release lily audience
i can release lil yachty and move on and
feel empowered about that choice
so but let's so let's go back in time
let's go back to a time when you were at
the cutting edge please let's go there
it is now the mid-2000s
oh yeah here we are
so let's talk about uh a question i like
to ask at the beginning is
so south garland high school what flavor
of
high school okay are we talking i can
present this
yes okay so this is a very large
texas high school it is the largest like
there's groupings of
of size this is a 5a meaning the largest
high school public high school
uh there were like over 2 000 kids there
my graduating class had like 750
students in it
um breakdown in court according to race
this high school was about 33 30
33 latinx black and white so
it was a diverse school um
and i had been going in to public school
my entire life and
i pretty much knew all the kids in my
grade i had gone to elementary middle
and high school with all of them
um and you know it was a beautiful time
to be alive it was a big football school
you know friday night lights it was very
very that mood yeah like how does it
stack
up to friday night very energy
very similar very similar football games
on the weekends
everybody in the town went to them if
you had a football player in your house
you had a billboard in your yard with
their face on it
literally it said home of so and so
number whatever
um if you were a cheerleader if you were
a drill team member you had a huge sign
in your yard that said a southern bell
lives here
yes that was the name of our drill team
the southern belle
southerner well so we were south garland
high there's a north garland high
there's a regular garland high
so we had this whole south motif which
is actually problematic
and they have since changed our mascot
and our theme song
um this is not the first time this has
happened many
this is happening all over the country
that actually makes me feel better
because
there is unfortunately like a shame to
that
um the confederate flag was used at my
high school
not when i was there but previously in
the past of the school i mean
it's really gross and um not okay
and they've since gotten rid of
everything i honestly don't even know
what their mascot is now
this just happened recently that's also
interesting so the
the last person to talk about this on
the podcast is akilah
hughes and her she's from kentucky and
her school they were the
rebels and yeah same so we were the
colonels very similar
okay so they just um she said that
they just there was a man named mr rebel
who was their mascot and they just
got rid of him stopped talking about him
nobody says anything about mr rebel
anymore
mr rebel we don't know him anymore he
can't come to the phone who
we were we were talking about that she
would like um open a drawer and actually
all the shirts like he had faded off of
them like
oh yeah he just like just a memory yes
he just faded away
like the leftovers just sort of went
yeah exactly
rip you know just you can't i don't know
where you went but you can't stay here
buddy bye bye mr rebel
bye-bye okay so where did you
fit into the social world
of south garland how do you make a
splash in a class of 700 kids
well i'll be honest with you i thrived
in high school
you could argue i peaked in high school
i had an amazing high school experience
i was class president i was student body
vice president
i was voted class favorite every year
i won the uh spring equivalent of
homecoming queen the colonel's lady is
what we call
it no yes i won
lady yes honey you are speaking to a
former colonel's lady right now
wow yeah and i was vice president of the
school
i was editor-in-chief of the yearbook i
was in one act play i was a
singer i mean i honestly killed it
and because of that confidence i think i
like when i moved to la i was like i got
this
you know what i mean if i took over
south garland high i can take over la i
can take over hollywood
yeah um so i had a lovely high school
experience i was a social butterfly i
was accepted in all the groups
um i had no ego i was i just really
played it well and
it was genuine it was genuine but i just
really thrived in that environment of
being amongst my peers
and uh i think my authenticity as a
person really
favored me yeah well i i do feel like
high school is a place where like
if you are a gregarious and friendly
person
you can you know right become you can
become the colonel's lady
that's true i mean i also feel like i
mean i was
a little [ __ ] i really was but i think
amongst all the other people i still was
like less of one than everyone else
because i look back and i cringe
sometimes i'm like oh i feel like i was
mean to that kid or oh i wish i hadn't
done that
or i was still coming into my own and i
was a
a victim of the 2000s you know uh
programming in many ways
oh yes and this is something obviously
we've all been thinking about
so much lately but i mean even with a
lot of the free
britney stuff right i
i i was also a pop punk princess
back in the day and i was very like emo
kid
like alts scene kids
whatever all of that stuff so i
really ate up a lot of that programming
of like britney is
actually like skanky and like all of the
like that kind of stuff and like girls
who are like that
like they suck they're not like me i
haven't i'm
so i'm so great and like above everybody
else and
exactly and it's like ugh i just want to
take that girl and be like
[ __ ] aren't real i know i i was no
i was just having this discussion on
another podcast about how virginity is a
social construct
yes and i oh gosh i just wish that that
all wasn't in my brain i just was so
like ashamed of sexuality and like
i just wish i would have gotten to suck
more dicks in high school honestly i
just wish i was freer to to experiment
more i was so
like worried about what people would
think and like just was too scared
see i was just like i did
you know i sucked a dick or two i guess
that's great i'm jealous but i was like
um i was really i i had a lot of
negative
thoughts around sex and like i
definitely was really concerned about
like other girls
and sex and what they were doing and
like definitely thought that like
[ __ ] girls were like a thing that i
needed to be worried about
in my life which is like so something
that i just got from like tv
oh yeah that's all it was we were
programmed to like hate other women
judge other women compare ourselves it
was just
and i hope that's not as bad today i i
feel like the teens are so much more
empowered now
i really hope that's the case i i
believe
like all good things about them like any
time i'm like well but now
high school is an oasis of progress
right
acceptance
let's break down all of these activities
that you
were said that you did so let's start
first because we are
ultimately a theater kid podcast
what plays were you doing okay
what roles did jackie tend to get in the
play
well i'll be honest i did not get my day
that's the one place where
i feel it didn't really serve me i was
always the funny side character
i never got to be the lead like my
senior year we did joseph in the amazing
technicolor dreamcoat
which i don't know if you're aware does
not have many female roles
no that's always a very strange
choice for like a high school to do
because i feel like high schools are
always
teeming with girls to be in the musical
and
there's always like four boys right and
also
honestly i talked about this on my
instagram a couple years ago and a bunch
of people dm me
people younger than me you know and they
were like oh no we had women playing the
brothers we had women play and i was
like
my high school was too square for that
this was texas bible belt in the 2000s
like
they would have never cause i would have
loved to play like benjamin's calypso i
would have loved to play one of the
brothers i would have been great
but that would have been great that that
wasn't an option you know the only
female roles are notoriously the
narrator which i'll be honest i'm a i'm
an alto too high for me
and podiver's wife who has one line and
that went to like the theater girl that
went to like our ingenue
and so because she also couldn't sing by
the way so
i was saying honey i was in the chorus
i busted my ass for an entire semester
to be in the chorus honey and there's no
shame in being in the chorus but like
i was so sad my senior year i was like
robbed of a
leading role or any kind of memorable
role
senior year in the chorus is really
painful
deep deep insecurity
my sophomore year i uh i was in the
chorus for a
little shop i got a part in the course
for a little shop and i said no
yeah the time to be in the chorus yeah
giving me bump me up or i'm walking
yeah excuse me i i believe there are
three do up girls and one of them should
be
me you would have slayed that yeah well
you just played that
they had the opportunity in uh 2006 to
make something happen for themselves and
they didn't so
you know the joke's on them
and i'm i i'm going to write a letter
because that's everyone he's right yeah
i would love for that for you all to do
the same for south garland be like
excuse me in 2003 y'all did joseph
manzie down the country coach jackie
johnson uh should have been one of i
mean
i could have ma what if they lowered the
narrator for me i mean is that crazy
the the thing is every school
play they should they should bend over
backwards to have
as many students be able to participate
and
like do fun things in the play they
should have had me be a brother i would
have been perfectly fine with that
um you know it didn't happen so i will
always go to bed at night and close my
eyes with the regret
that i didn't get a star in my senior
year i mean my rival high school did
into the woods
i almost transferred i was like i gotta
get out of here
because my dream role is baker's wife
jackie can i tell you something
we did it it's my senior year and my
biggest
so my big sadness that i've talked about
on this podcast is that i flubbed my
baker's wife audition
and i ended up as one of cinderella's
step sister then that's a fun role
though
but that's a fun role but it's not i get
it you don't get to
you don't bang the prince and then a
sexy song
i i hear you and i feel you in that
i feel you in that um i mean honestly i
would like to do any role in into the
woods it's my absolute favorite musical
of all time i would
i would love to play the witch i would
love to do a take on little red
i think that might be an interesting
choice i think you could be a great
little red
i mean i would be a tall red yeah
you know i mean i love that play
and um yeah so we'll see i mean it might
happen for me someday i don't know
you know what you can get casting into
the woods at any time there i might
not show up i might they might put it up
on clubhouse
it's so interesting how deep those like
like i remember every role that i felt
like i should have gotten
in high school and every like every
single time i felt like
slighted and it was such a um a
deep like drama for me same however it
really
set me up for the rejection i would
inevitably
you know experience in la every day for
15 years which is where we are now
so if if anything really it did me a
favor
i know now it's like oh my god i gotta
roll in the chorus yeah [ __ ] oh my
god i got an under five on brooklyn
nine-nine
ibooks the chorus thank you
it does you two learn to appreciate it
oh yeah i'll take the chorus any day if
i get my sag insurance back
yeah that's so what made you pursue
student government
i don't know that's a good question i
feel like i was very well liked
and wanted to sort of use that platform
to connect the school
you know interesting like the decisions
were being made
and honestly the student pres student
body president vice president did the
announcements every day and i was like i
need to do this
okay
i wanted to be the representative of the
school
and i was so in addition to the
announcements
what other like were you planning
of that we dances the dances and it was
a lot of work
but it was fun to like come up with the
themes which you know most of them were
appropriation i remember like we did
like arabian nights it's like what
oh yep why would we do that you know
like i don't even
you know under the sea oh homecoming
under the sea you know i if i could do
them now oh my god they would be so fun
yeah i really feel like um
we need a whole new list of themes for
dances
like all of the themes are played out
all the things they're done
our theme for prom was just forever
young yeah i think ours was um
uh like eternal friendship or something
it was so like
random i think it was like a gold
backdrop i mean it was nothing
yeah we're just getting into concepts
now like
what if we did like a bridgerton theme
see that regency i would want to get my
[ __ ] eight on the stairwell
i mean i would like make that happen
i i honestly actually can't imagine what
i would have felt if i had watched
bridgerton
as a teen right because it would i know
how the oc made me feel mm-hmm
um and that wasn't even as hardcore as
but what about the oc like imagine all
the beachy looks like
that i could i could [ __ ] with an oc
themed prom right now i could [ __ ] with
that that would you just have like a
little jean skirt
a low rise jeans skirt some hollister
flip-flops
a cami top oh yeah just one little cami
uh you know beautiful highlights
beautiful highlights
bronzer and a french tip nail
and you're good too and that tiny louis
vuitton like the one that you could only
hold like a pen
in yeah yeah yes 100
so what like tv etc were you
into in your teen years like who were
your celeb crushes
yeah okay so dawson's creek really
did it for me pacey specifically yes
that was kind of my
jam that was big um the oc hit in 03
and that was everything but i was in
college so we watched that all in the
dorm so in high school high school i'm
trying to remember like all those
all those 2000s movies legally blonde
she's all that
bring it on i mean i have them memorized
to this day
every line because they're so deeply
embedded into my psyche
from watching them so many times
i i feel the same way and it's like i
wonder if that's also
the like blockbuster and sleepover
culture a little bit where it was like
you rent it like
that was part of the activity and like
you would just rent the same i would
rent legally blonde although
i remember when i was really little me
my friend elizabeth had clueless on vhs
so we watched it
every sleepover and now it's like i can
you start a sentence from that movie and
i can just
i can like see the opening credits in my
head rolling like
exactly oh but my number one boo was
ashton kutcher
which cracks me up because i to this
i don't find him attractive in in the
slightest now
but i just had a thing for and i guess
it's some weird dad thing you know
really yeah
like six foot three blue-eyed
brown-haired white dudes
but that's
people said i reminded them of donna
because i had red hair in a deep voice
and so i was like
oh my god yeah i'm like a 70s girl and
me and ashton are gonna get married i
had
mrs kutcher underwear it said mrs
kutcher across the ass i got it like wet
seal
i'm telling you of course wet seal would
have misses oh yeah
underwear and honestly i kept them for
years i think i only got rid of them
like a couple years ago i should have
kept them because i could like give them
to my kids someday and they'd be like
what the [ __ ] is this
frame them and be like this is history
yes or if i meet him i can have him sign
them or something
yeah because he's around he was so
like he was so big at that time and like
just the idea of like
giant handsome white guys messing around
oh yeah
oh yeah like huge yeah the lead singer
of all american rejects
i remember like i was like i love how
funny he
is you know like he's just like a white
guy [ __ ] around
that's like the energy i feel like
started like as soon as they released a
funny music video
i was enthralled by their every waking
move those are my boys for life i mean
i i just got married three weeks ago and
in my wedding vows my husband said
you know uh i never thought i would fall
for a southern belle who puts the
beatles next to blink 182 and it's true
those are my two favorite bands
i i vibe with that so
hard to this day one of the most
transformative
experiences i have ever had with music
was listening
to take off your pants and jump oh yeah
walk man
as my parents drove to the jersey shore
and i just
felt you were immersed in that
experience
every emotion that's my favorite blink
cd
like it's incredible it is by far my
favorite and
the fact that you're a little bit
younger it's perfect because that was a
little most people would argue that they
had peaked at that point you know like
animal of the state was kind of like
their bread and butter
yeah but i think takeoff is my favorite
it is the pinnacle it is the album
what's your favorite track
uh it's really hard i feel like i need
to like
revisit to all of
it again and make a decision yeah yeah
but when i
think about takeoff the first song is
called the
anthem yeah yeah yeah okay and then part
two and the party anthem part two okay
when i think about it i
i know it's like that is the first song
but i imagine
like the jersey shore like washing like
going
by going past yeah as i'm pressing play
on it for like the third time
because it takes like five hours to get
to the jersey shore from dc so i just
listened to it
four or five hours over and over and
over again and so
i like what a time to be alive
what a time to be alive and thriving and
youthful in america truly
i mean truly and then i got to the
jersey shore and me and my friend megan
just like tried to kiss
other like all looking boys on this
whole world and it was the most glorious
beautiful god that brings a tear to my
eye honestly that sounds so lovely
it was so beautiful that's your version
of bridgeton you know
it really was yeah we had a we had a
whole thing where we would
um we would look for punk boys we would
watch them come out of the one
punk store that was on the boardwalk
and then we would follow them there had
to be two and then we would ask them
do you want to come on the tilt-a-whirl
with us it's better with more people
oh that's quite the line yeah
honestly to this day the slickest i've
ever supposed to say the game is strong
the game was so strong it's because of
blink man
did it work did y'all get like hot emo
dudes to go with y'all
absolutely it worked every time we
flashed
megan would flash her braces and we
would just
yeah be like come with us to the tells
the world i appreciate that
see that's that's the kind of [ __ ] i
would not do you know what i mean
so i would do it now what was teen
jackie's romantic
life i was like i was prude
and i was uh a shame
i i didn't even touch anybody till i was
in college i was very like goody goody
where did you have boyfriends at all
just like chastely or were you
no i i think senior year i started
because here's the thing like looking
back i was cute
oh yeah let's pull up let's pull up your
first photo let's see how cute you were
selling absolute cutie pie so
you'll appreciate this my t-shirt says
op you remember ocean pacific
yeah so this was like kind of a skater
girl look this is sort of an avril-esque
moment yes so i was still a little goofy
here i think this was freshman year
i got like a little i got like into my i
i remember looking in the mirror being
like wait i'm not a monster
am i like i think i i think i'm cute
like
but we're just conditioned to hate
ourselves and conditioned to not
appreciate
anything and and i think that's when it
took a turn like guys started noticing
me senior year but it took forever and i
was an extremely late bloomer i didn't
start my period until 16.
did you because i lived with this
constant feeling that the fact that i
did not
have enormous boobs was gonna like
something that everyone was
thinking about talking about was going
to follow me for my entire every room
that i walked
oh yeah i feel like that girl doesn't
have enormous boobs yes i felt like
everyone
i remember uh in i think it was eighth
grade a guy and i'd still know his name
because this was traumatizing
was going around snapping all the bras
on the backs of all the girls
and he got to me and i didn't have one
and he's like jackie johnson's flat as a
board and like everybody
and i remember no i was like i'm
humiliated that i don't have breasts
i'm humiliated that i don't have breasts
you know and in reality like i you know
i
it's great to have little titties it's
great to have whatever you have you know
but at the time i just
we always wanted whatever we didn't have
yeah i wanted yeah i wanted booty i
wanted curly hair i wanted everything i
didn't have i wanted blue eyes like
everything i didn't have i wanted
exactly i wanted well i wanted boobs and
i wanted
pin straight afro hair yeah yeah so
bad i was also really tall i was
5 10 when i entered high school and i
just wanted to shrink i was just like i
want to be petite i want to be small
i want to be you know a feminine i for
some reason i didn't equate it with
femininity and
i just wish i loved my body more and
appreciated it
yeah but there i mean when we think
about like
i mean first of all women have never
been taught to love their bodies ever
but as we're looking back on like the
90s and 2000s it feels like a
particularly yes
it was and difficult time and i'm only
really
now realizing how much of that
like was put in my head right
and stuff like i looked through old
yearbooks once and it
i was like oh this is so funny and then
um
i got to a place where i had written fat
on a picture and i was like oh my god
that makes me
first of all mortified second of all
like so ashamed
and third of all it makes me sad for my
old self right that i was so
concerned with my body that i'm also so
concerned with other people's bodies
that i'm gonna write that down like i'm
telling you it was
deep it really was a dark it was a dark
time
uh in terms of like uplifting others and
yourself
there are so many phrases that were
never said
and never taught to me and just concepts
that i had to really reprogram and focus
on as an adult
and and really kind of reprogram my
whole brain
yeah and if you think about like
representation on tv and stuff i'm
trying to think of representations of
like women who were friends
yeah and it wasn't about a man that they
were dating
right or like you know like
that's why broad city was such a
revolution when it came out and stuff
because it's like oh these two women are
just friends with each other in the show
i'm telling you that
that show is the voice of the generation
it's just so impressive in so many ways
it's good i actually never thought about
the impact it would have on the youth at
the time that's really powerful i'm
happy that they had something like that
yeah to just be like oh this is a show
about two cool girls who like each other
and they never talk [ __ ] about their
bodies they're very empowered sexually i
mean it's a
they're they cut the ground man right
and like i
if you broke that ground you watch back
shows that we were watching as kids and
it's like jennifer anderson being like
i'm on a diet yeah
like she's trash like oh my god but also
at home
too you know like you know i don't want
to get into
i mean my mom was always like like i'm
only eating raisins today like just like
all kinds of crazy [ __ ]
south beach dying reading in magazines
like crazy weird
read those i have them right here i i
collect like vintage magazines and by
vintage i mean like two thousands
magazines
uh and they're horrific they're horrific
and i'm like this is what was guiding me
through everything
i would pull out like the workout
routines that were in those and it's
like
why is there a workout routine in tnb
for 12 year olds
well it also says like look good in your
bikini for the boys like it's
so heteronormative and like gross and
i hate it i i just hate it all the body
types in this magazine are like
you know what you would imagine they are
it's just it was just it's all we had
though
we didn't have tick tock and youtube and
we didn't have trisha paytas and we
didn't have all these like people
explaining [ __ ] to us no not at all
speaking of people explaining [ __ ] we
were talking about you know you said you
were
not into you didn't you weren't dating
because you were
feeling nervous etc did you
what was the sex ed like at your school
oh zero zero
so in the bible bill which is crazy to
think about if
some of i mean if you if you went to
school in dc i don't know where you went
but you know my house
virginia my boyfriend went to this like
hippie school where they called the
teachers by the first names it was like
a completely different experience for me
no sex ed zero uh if you ask a question
they'll say wait till marriage so they
teach you abstinence only that's it so
nothing i knew
nothing i knew nothing isn't that and
did your requirements
give you anything or was it just like
book on the counter
well when my i had a friend in high
school get pregnant
and that's when my dad like because i
lived with just my dad
at one point i moved out my parents got
divorced all the [ __ ] and he was like
okay this is what happens this is how
you can get pregnant if you're gonna
have sex you need to be on birth control
if you need me to help you i'll get your
throat but you need to be on birth
control i mean that was pretty much what
he told me he was just like he was like
listen you're probably gonna have sex at
some point
get on birth control i'll help you if
you need me to and that's all we're
gonna say
just like the end of a pharmaceutical
commercial where they list all this yes
if you need birth control you can get in
touch with me but also please
don't say it that was it i learned
everything in college
thank god i went to a you know a liberal
college
i got there and they were passing
condoms out in the quad you know
and i went to the like health center and
the woman explained
everything to me i didn't know anything
that's wild and were you like did you
feel like
a lot of other people were in that city
where did you go to college
i went to university of texas in austin
oh okay so do you feel like
you there were other people who were
also similarly being like whoa
oh yeah i mean my my sophomore year in
college i lived in my sorority house and
my roommate was a virgin
and she was waiting till marriage and
then she decided to have sex with her
with her boyfriend and guess what they
are they're married and so she's only
had sex with him and good for her you
know
but like this is the kind of [ __ ] we
were all dealing with this is the
environment it was if you
and i remember everybody started around
me started like having sex and like
i remember just being like oh my god now
i'm a weirdo like
i have to have sex now everyone's doing
it i don't know what to do i don't know
do i need to shave my [ __ ] hair off
like what's happening like
it was so stressful yeah i'm getting
some
some people on tv are making it seem
like i have to shave my [ __ ]
i'm telling you i was in the car with
some friends and and
she like mentioned something and i go
wait you shave and she's like you don't
and like looked at me like i was a
monster and i was like i can't let
anybody near my [ __ ] until i figure out
what's going on here
like i don't know what to do i mean at
this point i was rocking a full
situation and that in 2003 that was not
the style oh no which is also like
crazy that i knew that because i was 13
in 2003 but i was aware that like it's
not
in vogue to have hair on me i'm trying
to think i think 2002 was the first time
a playmate
had no [ __ ] hair like a cover po and
and i remember it like it was the thing
and then all of a sudden it was all gone
and now it's like whatever goes
you know long short none styles
everything body hair in general whatever
you want
but it was really i was like if anybody
sees my because i remember i heard guys
talking
there was a bunch of guys hanging out
and they were like oh so and so suppose
he had long hair on it and i remember
like shaming this girl
in my grade and i was like i can't let
anybody see my [ __ ] until i figure out
what's going on here
i mean that is terrifying to tell you
guys talking like that terrifying but
that's what they did back then
i mean i'm sure they still do yeah but
it was you know
i don't think that's going away anything
yeah
yeah you know middle school middle
school
[Laughter]
i mean i would have loved to have a
conversation about like so-and-so's
stinky balls
like yeah they deserve it they deserve
it
they deserve so much it's like you're
gonna really
say something about [ __ ] hair when you
you're
just regular body smells yes you smell
you roll up to school smelling like [ __ ]
you need to shower honey you need to get
the salt the soap out
and soap up and rinse exactly exactly
coming at me
about what god made right exactly
like you have half a mustache and you're
gonna say something to me
don't come at me about hair get yours in
line
right you look ridiculous just going in
on a 12 year old boy
i mean i wish i could go back in time
truly storm in that cafeteria and be
like my [ __ ] is my
choice you're lucky i even let you look
at it
and i didn't let you look at it didn't
if i did
you would be lucky
so did you go to the dances with like
friends
or i so this is how it sort of worked in
the upper
like tier of popularity it was sort of
like
one girl got out of paper and put
everyone's names and decided who
everybody was gonna go with wow and and
i remember when i got to that level i
was relieved
because finding a date to the dances
always stressed me out because i had to
go to them i was throwing them
and i would win class favorite every
year which is a big deal it's basically
like the most popular award or whatever
so i had to go to the to the dance in
order to get my award so i was like oh
god who am i going to get like my
cousin's friend or like it was this
whole thing
so my senior year i was on the cool kid
list and like this girl whitney would
literally make a chart
she's like okay you're going to go with
chase you're going to go with rodney
you're going to go
chad like it was the whole thing so i
was so relieved
when i got to that level is uh i i bet
whitney is like an amazing person to
have in your
bridal party now oh i begged it out
she's just
she's the type a she's got the
spreadsheets going the emails are
you haven't been mowed me yet you have
five days to men mommy before there's a
finance tax so if you wouldn't mind
venmoing me for your
for your you know room in the airbnb um
i also asked you guys to text me
five things you like about jackie and i
yeah and some of you have not
sent them yet they do have to rhyme i've
been working on the streamers and they
are empty
and okay so let's take a look at this
photo because you do look is this a
dance
oh honey yes so the belly dress says
we're all the rage
in the early 2000s i am scandalized
that you were allowed to wear a belly
dress because the midriff was
quite forbidden at my high school at
dances or
not yeah well in in school hours oh no
no way but dances i guess they let you
and it's weird the southern culture like
my dad
loved this like southern dads i don't
know
they like their daughters to look hot
it's so weird i
i have several friends whose dads bought
them breast implants
as teens yeah it's a weird southern
i don't exactly understand it but i feel
a little tied to the like
this is my beautiful bounty it's
weird and i hate it but like my dad you
know
he had no issues with it and he also
knew i was a good kid like i was a
virgin in this photo
i wasn't i just liked to look cute i
wanted to be britney i wanted like a
britney like this is sort of genie in a
bottle-esque and that was i was gonna
say
this feels very um jeannie in a bottle
but also i'm a slave for you
yes
that is my biggest if i could roast my
teen self that was what i was saying i
was like honey get the [ __ ] out of that
tanning bed what do you think
you were roasting your teeth i was
roasting myself
truly in every sense i mean look how tan
i am you are very tan and you do have a
great ab
thank you honey we do our best that
dress was so tiny i can't even tell you
like i'm holding my water bottle right
now i'm like that dress would be too
tight for this bottle
it was so small do you remember where
you got it
oh yeah of course i do whatchamacallit
what should we call it was the store
it's i think it's still in dallas it's
it's called whatchamacallit and it is
the formalwear store and the thing that
sucks is that every
girl goes there to get her dress so you
would show up and like three girls would
have your dress on and you would be like
you need to [ __ ] leave
you need to leave we cannot be at the
party at the same time i will leave in
half an hour then you can come like
but nobody had that dress this year this
year did anyone have this
this was my junior year i went to senior
prom with a senior and i got this dress
for that and that's a guy named jay
and we nothing happened between us he
was like a bible thumper kid and you
know wanted nothing to nothing to do
with that
but i did look hot and i did get to go
to the senior prom as a junior which was
exciting and that's all that matters
that's all that matters
that's that's a way more valuable memory
than if you two
had fingered yeah i mean honestly i wish
we had you know looking back
but but that wasn't on my agenda for the
night and um it is what it is you know
so okay because you are the beauty talk
shock jock what was
tea and jackie's beauty routine at the
time i mean you mentioned
that we're in the tanning beds what are
what are her products oh yeah i i can
just
putting herself together yeah i can tell
you everything so again these magazines
were really the bible for me
so i would whatever the ads were in
these magazines i would buy whatever it
was a lot of times it was like the
covergirl aqua smooth you know like just
some crappy gross top
and i'm like right here it's like
covergirl mascara
i would go yep i'm getting that stuff
where we found out later it's like oh
actually there's so much of this in the
ocean it's oh yeah whales
oh yeah this will kill a whale in a
minute flat but we're rubbing it all
over our bodies
and i would always get a shade you know
very
orangey because again i was so tan
artificially tan so i would do like a
covergirl
kind of liquid foundation and like a
frosty eye look with a mascara
no eyeliner no contouring no like
different colors of the palette
and like maybe kind of a gloss and
that's it
honey the eyebrows were suffering they
had no help
yeah at that point i had already
destroyed them i mean if you look in
that photo i have like a tiny little
parenthesis of an eyebrow they were gone
i didn't kill them kids are
the kids are plucking their brows again
see that i do i for the most part i
don't think that millennials should be
making weird videos talking to jen's
ears on tick tock but i do think that we
should step in here
and yeah like a ps4 to do that yeah just
be like
hey i know you think we're annoying but
we just want to let you know that
you could hurt yourself here yeah it's a
slippery slope i just
i again it's self-loathing i hated my
eyebrows they were beautiful they were
big and art big arches and i just was
like i don't want these i want little do
bear more eyebrows i want to look like
with sanguler
and i just ruined i literally killed
them
yeah i literally killed them and it's a
it's a big regret
hashtag regret that's a big one it's
letting my eyebrows be ruined
uh that is i mean i wasn't i wasn't as
eyebrow concerned at the time because
like i was like
being punk but i i [ __ ] my hair up
really bad
bleaching it and putting manic panic in
it and then i would like dye it myself
and my whole ear would be purple
for a week i had a lot of diy fails i
tried to
do you remember those uh highlighter
caps yes
you would basically put this cap on your
head and it came with this little hook
and then you'd stab it in
pull your hair out so you sort of look
like a potato
you know a tia thing
and then i did that and then i was i
took the cap off and i was like it
didn't get my roots
so i poured like peroxide [ __ ] on the
roots
and then i had a yellow like a banana
yellow streak going down my scalp
and i had to go emergency to like the
pharmacy to get a brown hair dye like
and i was like [ __ ]
i don't know why there were no tutorials
nobody was helping me here no
oh my god the the things that i would
have not done to my hair if i had had
youtube tutorials right
uh instead of just kind of being like i
think that i've seen them do this on tv
it's crazy to think about doing
something to your hair
and having no instruction
it is wild but that's what we did we
didn't have anybody even like
the makeup tutorials in these magazines
are nothing it's like one photo
and it's like swipe the green across
your eyelid and i'm like okay how can i
[ __ ] that up
i'd [ __ ] it up oh yeah i was also just
like looking at other girls on myspace
and trying to like recreate what they
were oh yeah
i didn't even have that well
it opened up a whole other can of worms
for me obviously
all right i think we've got one more
photo of you that we should
talk about okay i feel like this is a
great
going back to your teen jackie style
oh yeah i am loving so we've got like a
low
rise jean short and a fringe belt
which i love i bought that in la when i
came to look at colleges so i came back
to school and i was like
um aren't i [ __ ] trendy although this
was not taken to school i could never
wear shorts that short at school and i
could never wear
my belly hanging out yeah
i'm sure so being that you're like a
tall person and just looking at you here
i feel like you probably could never
wear shorts no because art was always
fingertips
same yeah and i would basically be
wearing pants
yeah i'm looking at what a fingertip
length short would be on for you and
it's
like a culotte and you know
that's a mood now but culottes were not
fly in o3
they were not they were not considered
cool but it's funny i saw this photo and
i looked at those shoes
and i remember a couple years ago there
was a meme that said if you wore these
shoes in high school it's time for a
night serum
and it was these shoes they're like
steve madden like uh
wedge kind of sandals and i remember
being like when i saw this what i was
like oh [ __ ]
that cut me deep i need it i need a
serum luckily i i'm a big serum head but
yeah yeah but the hosts are the most
serious i'm the host of the most hairs
but but that that cut me deep i was like
yeah this is the time period it's time
to wear
ladies get the serums out if you're in
your 30s get those serums out
it's if sometimes a meme will hurt you
and that's like the worst way to be hurt
yep i agree because then you realize
it's like the zeitgeist mm-hmm
your pain is the zeitgeist yes and it's
like you're not even original that
you're hurt
it's just so i'm i'm still fixated on
this belt here i do feel like the early
2000s we did a lot of experimentation in
bell
yes and there were a lot of like
big hang off the waist belts kelly
clarkson this was sort of in her
era you know she just won american idol
at the time like
like a really big belt that really
served no purpose
other than an artistic statement yes and
i feel like
i feel like this is a belt that i would
see
on lindsay lohan at
thank you so much yes like and like the
video
like a trl appearance and she's wearing
a jean skirt
over cut jeans yes yes yes
yes that is something i will never
understand i will never understand
why that happened how that happened but
yes this that's exactly what i was going
for here
we were we we were wearing skirts over
boot coaching
back in the day yep yep we sure were in
like a
like a a kangal hat absolutely
yes absolutely like a bucket hat
and um and the shirt would be layered as
well
yes yes of course maybe a baby tee under
the dress
i this was a style that i that i loved
and we were talking on a recent episode
about like
billabong quick silver fashion yep yep
a shirt that was just one shirt
but it looked like multiple you had
a short sleeve shirt with a long sleeve
shirt underneath yes
yeah it was sort of like built in layers
you didn't have to really worry
dude too much effort but we were all
that's the ice pack i have around my
neck by the way that's why you know
you're in your 30s like oh i pulled my
neck oh
oh my peloton oh i slept wrong
oh no i know oh uh but yeah the surf
clothes and there i was nowhere near a
beach let's just
set things up i was in dallas texas
there was no beach anywhere near me
but we were like oh my god abercrombie
beach girls like let's all wear
beach outfits and like billabong and
ocean pacific again
that was like our whole thing we like
pretended like we were like beach girls
the the vibe of the hollister store at
the mall
i don't think can ever be recreated it's
still there
it's still and it's oh my god chugging
along like that little cabana
the cabana is there and it's why is it
so
dark you can't even see the clothes
it's so dark in there and like you know
the beach it's so
loud the music is
so loud like you feel it pulsating
through your veins
really it i remember in well
it was a huge deal because i had just
moved from los angeles to northern
virginia when hollister
dropped so i kind of had this idea i
remember at the time like
i'm gonna i'm gonna use this i'm gonna
hitch a ride on this
and be like well i'm from l.a
hollister's
from l.a you're like hi i'm nice to meet
you
i'm kind of like hollister it me
did not work at all plan fell apart
immediately i did not uh
own hollister clothes well see i did
i was all about that i mean i remember
there was these shorts i wanted
they were so short you could see my
colon
i mean they were they were a thong and
they were cut off and i was just like
they were like 98 dollars i don't know
and i was just like i saved up all
summer i'm like i'm gonna get those
booty shorts i'm gonna look so good in
those [ __ ] shorts
and they were from hollister and they
were like the cool hot girl shorts
i remember i tried to save up to buy the
top of a bathing suit from hollister
just the top yeah cause then you could
rock bottoms with it like a jean or yeah
exactly i was like well i got these
bottoms from target
yeah so i'll say that's smart yeah
invest in the piece
that's going to get the most attention
that's smart
that is what i did that is tina elise
was industrious um
all right jackie we're coming up on the
end here so these are the last two
questions i like to ask
do you remember any big scandals
drama rumors from your high school
oh yeah of course um i know her name
to this day i'm not going to say it so
again this was bible belt culture
women were shamed for being sexual boys
were praised you know
same old stuff there was a girl who was
a cheerleader and she let her boyfriend
put it in her butt this is a very common
thing in southern cultures it's sort of
like the loophole like jesus won't mind
if you go in the back but he will mind
if you go in the front so
i guess she and her boyfriend were like
okay let's try this
and she was like it wasn't going in it
wasn't going in
so they said well we need to like lube
it up somehow what do we use he got his
doc martin boot oil
no which we all had doc martens you know
so this is of the times so
he i guess it happened and she made the
fatal mistake of telling a couple people
or he maybe told everybody
and that poor girl to this day is known
as doc martin
to this day and people would be like oh
there's a there's a
oh there's a mark on my foot go get
so-and-so's ass you know it was horrible
it's horrible and i feel bad for her
because you know obviously
we want to be empowered in our sexuality
we want to be empowered in our choices
and it's just
because there was no knowledge or
information they thought that that would
be okay
and it was you know that's not a good
choice everybody if you want to if you
want to do butt stuff
please do not use stock market oil get
coconut oil you know
buy a lube there's plenty of them out
there
yeah see this is again why we actually
do need sex
ed and yes so that we know not to put
the boo
martin oil in the boot yeah yeah yeah
boot oil in the boot honey and it is
funny in theory but i still think about
that poor girl and like how
how hard that must have been for her to
to live down
yeah that's that's a really tough one my
the the example i always i always give
on the pod
is also but related i remember a girl
whose name i also
fully remember um i remember and i
remember where i was sitting on the bus
when i found out that at a party that
weekend she had put a remote control in
her butt
there's a lot of that too yeah there's a
lot of like
bottles like and and i'm just i don't
understand like i guess
well actually i feel like i do
understand i think i was like curious
you remember like you're brushing your
teeth and you kind of go hmm
interesting and some people just they
take it the next step further
they perform and then we're getting
drunk for the first time and things are
happening and
somebody puts a remote control in their
bud somebody uses doc martin boot oil
right things happen in your youth you
know these are the
you're supposed to experiment it's
healthy it's normal
i just am sad that her story became
fodder
for everybody else and me as a 36 year
old woman
remembering it like it happened
yesterday that's the thing is like
it you actually you want to be able to
say like you live that down but it's
like here you are and you do fully
remember
everything i also like i want to like
apologize to her
well yeah that's mine even though she
wasn't in my grade so i wasn't i never
participated in the act of like you know
going to her and shaming her anything
but
you know i think back on like sort of
similar situations and
friends and i'm like oh i just feel so
bad and i just hate that that was part
of our culture
and yeah i don't think um
i don't think young women were taught
how to be good friends to each other yes
for a really and we were actually
actively taught how to be like
terrible friends to each other and i
know that that affected me
for sure yes i'm telling you if i could
redo high school curriculum it would be
there would be a class on what is a
narcissist how do you spot one
how do you remove them from your life
and it is perfectly okay that you do
that
number two how do credit cards work
let's talk about credit scores let's
talk about how to
save up how to keep money how to you
know these are the like that would be
what i would teach
instead of like monday the scarlet
letter
yes exactly like how do you keep a
kitchen
cute how do you cook for yourself
that i mean yeah that would have been
uh very very helpful and i think would
have been great for a lot of the people
who were my first roommates
if you haven't taken some of these
lessons yeah same
jackie it has been so amazing having you
on the podcast we have one final
question that i ask
all of my guests which is if you could
talk to teen jackie today
what would you tell her okay here's what
i would tell her i would say be kind to
yourself
be kind to yourself and enjoy
this time in your life because you take
it for granted you don't have to pay
bills
you don't have to deal with you know
jobs and [ __ ]
enjoy your life why don't you go get
finger a little bit
you know maybe maybe get your butt
tickled i don't know
just experiment feel confident in that
feel empowered in your choices sexually
get the [ __ ] out of the tanning bed get
the [ __ ] out of the tanning bed i
understand that you want to look tan in
your belly dress i understand but
just take it from me get the [ __ ] out of
the tanning bed
and put the tweezers down honey i just
these are things that i just i wish
somebody i just
take it from me and and wear sunscreen
every day and i know nobody else does it
and i know it doesn't say to do that in
your teen magazines but just
put sunscreen on every day get out of
the tanning bed don't don't plug your
eyebrows and like
maybe go get some put in your butt but
just
don't use don't use doc martin oil
whatever you do oh that is
perfect i think we're i think that
that's
a message a timeless message for a
timeless message teenagers of all ages
and honestly everybody any yeah actually
you know what this is a timeless message
for people of any age
of any creed
any social economic group any region of
the world
100 well jackie it was amazing to have
you on the pod
and uh for everyone listening at home
this has been the roast of your teenage
self podcast
you